there's this guy Chris on on Mr BEAST's
YouTube channel Mr Beast biggest YouTube
channel and this guy Chris is married
with a kid and Chris has just decided
that he's a woman now
which I imagine was not a pleasant thing
for his wife to hear a very cruel thing
to do to his son puts Mr Beast in a
terrible position because Mr Beast tries
to remain apolitical but now his
sidekick is is taking on the most
controversial issue in all of politics
right now and what is Mr Beast going to
do
as of now Mr Beast is defending his
friend and employee and he's attacking
the transphobes that is not
probably not a good winning path in the
long run because there are a lot of
transphobes if by transphos we mean
people who just rationally understand
that men and women are different and Men
Can't become women if you start
attacking that transphobes I don't think
that's going to be great for your 100
plus million view videos but back to
Chris
I mentioned on the show I I don't really
care
about this guy Chris's opinions on
transgenderism or sex or the compositive
Body and Soul or anything like that I
don't even really care that much about
Mr BEAST's opinions on YouTube
but I asked the question
how does a guy wake up at the age of 26
with a wife and a child and decide that
he's a woman
and I suggested that the aspect of this
whole transgender phenomenon that people
are not really talking about is porn
that porn is driving a lot of this and I
I even had that thought because I was
speaking to a reporter who had done a
little bit of a deep dive onto all the
kind of weird porn I'm not I'm not
saying this reporter was sort of
prowling late at night on the secret
browser tab or anything like that but
she had gone gone down this Rabbit Hole
of a specific type of porn that men who
have rapid onset gender confusion
attribute their confusion to this I
started watching this porn which is kind
of a hypnosis and then what do you know
I can't get it out of my head and it's
melted my brain and now I think that I'm
a woman
so Ali Stuckey
our great friend Alex Stuckey dug up an
old tweet from this guy Chris on the Mr
Beast show and she said in a tweet that
he just deleted Chris from Mr Beast who
recently announced he's transitioning to
a woman says he likes lowly which is
l-o-l-i which is a form of anime porn in
which the female characters are depicted
as children or even babies
man many many such cases among trans men
I don't know what this guy Chris meant
by that comment where he had made this
whole comment about how much he lusted
after this genre of pornography I'm not
saying it means that he's a pedo I I'm
not saying it wasn't even just a joke on
Twitter but what is undeniable from this
is that this guy Chris knows a lot about
porn
if you're familiar enough with porn to
make a joke about this obscure
Sub sub genre of pornography then you
know a lot about porn which would seem
to back up my thesis which I I said on
the show is just a hunch I'm not I don't
know this guy Chris there's I haven't
read any scientific study with a lab
coat but I strongly suspect that if you
start to have really bizarre sexual
ideas and desires it might have
something to do with the ubiquity of
bizarre extremely high-tech pornography
that is warping people's minds and that
they write people write into this show
even sometimes they'll say I got hooked
on porn at age 10 and it's been a
struggle for my whole life maybe that's
something that politicians should do
something about
speaking of the justice system
speaking of transgender identifying
people
there is a dude who thinks that he's a
chick who attacked a Catholic Church
he was finally arrested for this this
guy destroyed religious property
this is a crime that holds a maximum
prison sentence of one year up to a one
hundred thousand dollar fine up to five
years probation supervised release
following prison so this is
this is pretty serious
and the Biden doj just recommended no
jail time
of course it did the Biden doj
Biden FBI which sends agents in to spy
on Catholics who go to mass on Sunday
the Biden doj and FBI which then tried
to deny that they were spying on
churches and and viewed Catholics as
potential domestic terrorists we then
found out this was a real program it
wasn't just a one-off memo that that
nobody knew about this was a program by
the FBI there were there were agents
assigned to cultivate sources to try to
flip priests to violate the inviolable
Seal of the confessional potentially and
to to rat to the federal government on
their flock
and then
a member of the protected religion the
protected Cult of transgenderism goes
and attacks the persecuted religion
Christianity and specifically
Catholicism and he gets off scot-free
this is how it works
this is how the the I don't need to tell
you that you're well aware of that
but the the liberal regime the Elites in
power with the bow ties don't wear bow
ties with the long neckties and the very
fancy jackets and they've got the really
fancy offices in Washington DC they're
not going to go out and commit Street
crime but Street crime is important for
them to maintain their political
dominance and so what they do is they
just encourage all sorts of miscreants
to commit commit the street crime for
them and then they let them off the hook
and then they bail them out of jail and
then when BLM is marauding all over the
country for eight months Kamala Harris
raises money to bail the
the criminal BLM activists out of prison
Joe Biden staffers raise money to bail
BLM out of prison so what does that do
that creates an incentive
for more of the street crime which
intimidates conservatives and Christians
and normal people
who are now going to think twice before
speaking out because they don't want
their Church destroyed they don't want
their pro-life Pregnancy Center
destroyed they don't want their homes
destroyed they don't want to be attacked
in public by people who will have
impunity to do it
speaking of corruption in the
administration
the Pentagon Inspector General has found
that corruption in Ukraine funding and
arming
is very very high risk
the defense department recognizes
Ukraine's history of corruption and
considers the possibility of Aid being
deflected before it reaches its intended
target to be a high risk
another official at the Pentagon is
concerned about weapon systems that
we're sending over there and the theft
of those weapon systems they say this is
according to an official being reported
by defense one DOD procedures the most
advanced systems in the world there are
many entities to include foreign Nations
as well as criminal groups that want to
get their hands on weapons technology
Etc which raises the question that I've
been asking since day one on all of this
Ukraine stuff namely
what are we funding
what's the goal here
because from my position it feels like
our sclerotic leaders are sleepwalking
us into World War III
what's the end goal here
we could have prevented the war easily
Joe Biden Donald Trump did prevent the
war Donald Trump is the president on
whose watch uniquely among recent
presidents Vladimir Putin did not
further invade any foreign Nations
but Biden comes into Power he could have
prevented The Invasion probably he could
have done that by maintaining sanctions
on Russia even according to the Ukraine
President Vladimir zielinski
Biden lifting those sanctions impelled
Russia to invade then what happened
then Biden said if it's just a minor
incursion we won't do anything about it
that's fine further encourages Russia to
invade
then the United States funds the war
says we're going to fund the war into
perpetuity
so now the war continues to escalate
you've got now explicit threats of
nuclear war Russia is saying it's not
even a cold war anymore Russia is saying
we are directly in a hot conflict with
the United States and then you look over
there
at China and you see China beginning to
aggress on Taiwan and the South China
Sea it just feels like we're slow
walking into World War III so what are
we doing here we're funding Ukraine to
the tune of billions and billions of
dollars over 100 billion dollars
what do we want do we want Ukraine and
NATO I don't
is that the plan do we want Ukraine in
the European Union
that doesn't seem like a great idea
either but let's tell let's figure out
what
what the plan is do we want do we want
to invade Russia do we want war with
Russia do we What's Happening Here do we
want a buffer state in Ukraine which I
think would have been smarter what are
we funding
seems like we're just funding more and
more corruption with no end in sight
producer Colton has brought me my iPad
so I get to chat with you in the
membrane segmentum which begins now head
on over to dailywire.com Knowles I will
need your help to ascertain which of the
headlines are fake which of them are
real dailywire.com Knowles use code
knows you'll get two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
oh
foreign